[Music]
all right guys
welcome to punishment bingo
[Applause]
here's how this is going to work it's
just like regular bingo
only when you win when you hit bingo we
flip a coin
and you either get a prize or you have
to do something terrible
you could be punished for winning just
like real life
oh 67.
[Applause]
how can i wait for punishments
you guys are so great all right here we
go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
head surprise tails of punishment
[Laughter]
hey
[Applause]
a terracotta soldier
[Applause]
[Music]
punish me
[Applause]
[Applause]
pick you up
[Music]
[Music]
hey scott how's it goin
what is it
oh god
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is all natural clam juice i don't
know if you guys can see it there
jackson you got it gotta take a swig
maybe it won't be that bad
all right
wait wait wait wait wait oh my god
that's a way for me to step away from
this
clam juice
it smells just like lamb juice
[Music]
oh you know what it says right here
perfect for chowders and sauces
[Applause]
get over there on the camera
get over there
[Music]
oh
oh
[Applause]
dude
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]